welcome to the global roundtable this
series focuses on the future of economic
competition I'm Parag Khanna joined by a
very distinguished panel including dumby
samoy Oh Daniel Altman and uninsured
hard us today we're focusing actually on
whether or not bankers should be thrown
behind bars and there are all kinds of
cliches now about how Wall Street should
be treated in the aftermath of the
financial crisis they privatized gains
and socialized losses and so forth but
we haven't really answered the question
because not enough has actually been
done about it so what are we going to do
with the bankers well I think we need to
treat them the way we would treat people
who make mistakes in almost any sector
we need personal responsibility because
right now the buck stops with
shareholders and whether taxpayer
picking up the bill or a bunch of
shareholders we're defusing the
responsibility away from the people who
really make the bad choices and they're
the executives we need personal
responsibility for them we saw it with
sarbanes-oxley when CEOs and CFOs had to
personally sign their financial
statements all of a sudden they wanted
to know what was in them right that's a
big step in the right direction
absolutely most people work in the
financial industry including the people
who run financial institutions will
agree that something went wrong but I
think to focus specifically on bankers
and penalizing bankers without really
looking at the broader context is to
miss a bigger point the responsibility
of governments is to provide free public
goods things like education and health
care and infrastructure and so on
provision of regulation and also
precepting a policy environment that
makes things work those are the three
responsibilities of governments and it's
absolutely clear that in the context of
derivatives in the context of the
financial crisis the government's
definitely fell down we have yet to find
this middle ground between the
government responsibility to regulate
and yet the economy and the business
sectors need to have freedom to be
creative and to be entrepreneurial where
is that middle ground going to be in
this country Thanks our means to an end
there lubricants of other people's
commerce they've always been in the
background wearing those gray suits
being conservative helping other people
take risks make iPads etc at some point
we all got confused not just bankers
into thinking about banks as an end in
themselves in fact the only real ended
in itself in the American economy the
most dynamic thing the thing that every
smart undergraduate wanted to do when
banks step out front and become the star
it's a very dangerous thing I don't
think we've learned that lesson fully
hold on a second we have to stop calling
them banks because financial
institutions are also insurance
companies hedge funds we have a whole
bunch of different animals out there
right now the problem is that we don't
even know what they're doing forget
regulation we don't even have the
monitoring but we'll never see a crisis
coming if we can't see what's actually
going on in this industry you laterz
that have been guilty of two things not
only are they have been asleep with a
switch so to speak not paying attention
to all of the things that banks we're
doing but they also don't necessarily
have the technical competence to
understand it which is why don't you
think that actually the financial
industry needs to have some self
monitoring mechanisms in a way because
only they can actually know what they're
doing well there are ways that we're
looking at now in the financial sector
to help banks to assess what their risks
would be based on the risks of other
banks and that's a step in the right
direction too but we'll never really
close the circle until we have global
monitoring because all of the financial
markets are global right now if we only
have regulation or monitoring in a few
traditional centres then all of the
activity that we're trying to stop the
herd behavior and the exotic trades will
just move offshore and we need to be
very conscious that that's a risk for
our markets too we actually get this
right in a number of professions
airplane pilots when they're up there
are not trying to optimize for getting
the biggest raised in deciding how to
land there's a kind of ethic on the best
landing the safest land they're pretty
aligned with the passengers in terms of
their incentives no fair enough but I'm
just saying there's a number of
professions in which we get this right
in which we in which we don't get people
to very narrowly think about one
variable so I don't think we can take it
for granted that in this industry people
are incapable we pay executives
corporations and banks based on
performance and that's really what
they're driving to achieve I mean it's
notes no there's no interest for them to
have these institutions glow on but at
the same time they do look for guidance
with regulators and policymakers in
order to define what the framework is
where they work but we need to pay them
for long-term performance when we start
paying them for short-term that's when
we run into problems we're all to
stretch on under the analogy we're all
in the same economic jumbo jet and it's
a long haul life thanks very much for
your insights more on this and other
very pertinent topics related to the
future of the global economy at big
thing calm
you